hey guys I'm Ryan right and I'm Aaron
today Aaron and I are checking out the
trailer for a rise of the Tomb Raider
the gameplay demo released at e3 2015
you ready for this Aaron yeah I'm right
anyone who played the last Tomb Raider
big reboot on those that she can do this
so I'm I'm interested to see the further
adventures of Laura Croft and the new
version that can do this oh yeah now
she's good at doing this yeah Xbox
exclusive holiday 2015 any holiday next
year just Halloween
[Music]
lighting a flare is of this oh there's I
can't really make out her ass ultimate
Laura Croft look at her ass um things
have changed in the franchise
dramatically
wait please get a few lar
[Music]
this might be the kind of job for second
place I can just I can still just really
appreciate Italy like well crap didn't
barn yeah
what do you think
oh okay
[Music]
it's big black on this is something
operatives
[Music]
he's an ethnically ambiguous chap I
assume he may be a sure interesting well
it was sound I was about to say it's
like the new redesign alarm for after
the last game was getting some she looks
like Ellen Page black but now it's like
whoa oh now this is the hose that I can
make it
Laska him was I can do this as soon as I
can make it
as business looks this plane plane
doesn't well
[Music]
I mean cinematically is gorgeous but
like gameplay-wise it doesn't look the
most fun this just looks like a bunch of
QuickTime events
[Music]
normally when you think you think
gameplays are you nothing like glorifies
me like time pets
[Music]
[Music]
maintaining the tradition of long
process getting her ass ruined every
cloud point of the game man use that big
black dog
[Music]
this looks like a less fun version of
uncharted
I can't tell if any of this is actual
gameplay because I'm not seeing button
prompts so I can tell from these arrival
time events
our gameplay our gameplay trailers just
to cut scene early intense one but it's
a demo
there was only one button prompt that
okay now this looks vaguely actually
directly
now she's still pretty hot
I mean she looks like Ellenbogen
elephant they just not been unattractive
person this game got a lot cooler
okay there's that's the second button
prompt the X you do actually interact
with this game confirm for not just
being a movie
[Music]
[Music]
right now I'm having a hard time selling
between like ain't playing yeah
[Music]
all thing else dwells in the darkness of
this place but I've got to continue
[Music]
I finally feel a sense of purpose again
like I'm doing what I was meant to do
some kind of marker rain too
the journey will be parallel I must find
a way
[Music]
not entirely sure how I feel about that
to be honest like parts of it look
really cool other parts of likeness and
this one look like it'd be fun to play
and a lot of it looks does look very
uncharted like I played on Charlie I've
seen the trailers for part 4 and this is
an Xbox exclusive on charter was a
PlayStation exclusive so I feel like
they're trying to get their Uncharted
exclusive I've been well sorry to be
that guy but that's just what it feels
at the same time Tomb Raider is like a
decade plus old franchise so it's like
you can say Oh Uncharted clearly kind of
took its cues from from Tomb Raider from
the get-go but I mean now that tomb
Raider's kind of been rebooted the two
franchise have clearly been
cannibalizing each other for back and
forth for you know since they got off
the ground
well they both kind of had an Indiana
Jones vibe yes it's it's both like you
know our video game version of being
Indiana Jones you're in the ruins of
some lost civilization getting treasure
and run crazy disasters and I'm not
above appreciating you know like really
heart pounding like QTE Laden sequences
of running from [ __ ] going wrong as
you're just trying to like platform
across an environment I'm not above like
really enjoying that immersion factor in
that tension but this feels like you
haven't given me anything new to really
react to this is just like sizzling
hashed yeah like this is I mean this is
one of those games where I feel like
people are gonna say why is this its
standalone title and not like an
expansion or a deals yeah why why do I
need to pay full retail for this
quote-unquote
sequel I feel like it's meant for fans
who are already fans of the game you
know what I mean like yeah only people
who are already invested into if you if
you really need more of the last Tomb
Raider game here is more of the last
Tomb Raider gasps some new some new
narrative stuff and snow I just don't
see how like a new person who's not that
familiar with tumor
would actually be that drawn to this to
be honest this is probably something if
you're if you're getting on board Tomb
Raider in its current iteration you're
going to jump on just Tomb Raider the
last game that this is I suppose a
sequel to and then it's like oh I want
more of that well there's there's more
already the pipe for you yeah the pipe
let's look at the back okay not a sex
joke that's I was drug jokes is drug
jokes drug jokes this is judge jokes
we're what's the word we're right now
yeah we're diversifying the profile
dinner yeah sex drugs black [ __ ] let's
do this anyway guys thanks for tuning
into the real rejects if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can catch Aaron on dank
ass Stubbs with our buddy Jerry here on
the real rejects check that out fun
podcast there you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter and vine is
if we get enough followers we can get
product placement more than we've
already gotten people making the money
[Music]
Nicholas Rivera hey Ryan I wonder if I
could get a shout-out there are six
reasons why should okay one I love your
channel - dick jokes are awesome c3 you
seem pretty cool for Assassin's Creed is
awesome don't know why I [ __ ] said
that just looking for another reason 5
dawn of Justice dawn of Justice looks
awesome and six and last but not least I
can tell my friends and family to follow
you and watch your video so you can get
more view subs and product replay spanks
according to him yeah I did a lot of
products replace do you think do you
have any broken [ __ ] yeah his family
members will just bring replacements to
your place you really like a shout-out
sure Nicholas Rivera you can totally
have one Nicolas Rivera is actually a
young Hispanic lad whose father would
have had no idea his father is part of
the Mexican Mafia I that I mean that
feels like a big guess I mean no it's
it's a fact you know Nicholas Rivera and
this feels like a like wild flavored
speculation names Rivera and Rivera is
Mexican so his dad is naturally a part
of the Mexican yeah but it's the way
things work but Nick Rivera he could
also be like a shy stirring pseudo
Russian doctor on The Simpsons is this
your Jewish mentality talking no I'm
saying like dr. Nick Riviera sorry yeah
he's the guy who says hi to everyone
hi everybody that's exactly the guy oh
hi dr. Nick yeah yeah thanks your dad
visit your dad tell us if he's in the
Mexican Mafia or if he's if he's a
Simpsons don't we need to know we have
to know